[Musique]
les dinosaures s'installent à la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Eveline
regissement animaux en taille réelle
espèces articulés au total 20 animations
de tricératops 10 plodocus et autres
mamouth les enfants forcément passionnés
par ces animaux préhistorique ont chacun
leurs préférence concernant les
activités
[Applaudissements]
proposées le film le
film
bah c'est un monsieur en fait il va sur
unele des
dinosaures j'ai dinosaure parce
[Musique]
que c'est
passionnant il y en a qui font peur et
il y en a qui sont drôles j'ai
préféré la télé et aussi les ici et
là-bas d'accord j'ai beaucoup aimé ça
j'ai plein de livres
de de de dinosaur sous le chapitau les
enfants de 6 à 12 ans découvrent
l'exposition et répondent au quiz
distribués à l'entrée 20 questions sur
l'univers des dinosaures où vivait-il
que mangeait-il quand ont-ils disparu
l'exposition se veut éducative on trouve
toutes les réponses sur les panneaux au
cours de la visite mais bon il faut
quand même lire donc c'est pour les
enfants c'est assez éducatif c'est
pédagog
et bon voilà vraiment chercher tout ça
une fois le quiz corrigé les enfants
repartent avec un petit diplôme en
souvenir de
l'exposition